all right time now for the Hannity Hot
Seat many illegal immigrants will likely
find a new home in the sanctuary State
of California which is already unable to
take care of their own homeless
population they're facing about a 24
billion dollar budget deficit in an
interview with foxnews.com one local
resident from San Francisco described
the city's deterioration including bus
stops that have been hijacked by drug
dealers open-air drug markets on the
city streets addicts acting erratically
on block after block so just who's to
blame here keep in mind there has not
been a Republican mayor of San Francisco
since
1964. here now with reaction co-host of
the five Geraldo Rivera
I'm going to say something and I I say
this it's good to see you happy New Year
um you have
so too far so lenient on the issue of
illegal immigration now I did get you to
concede that building a wall you said
okay I'll be okay with that but under
Joe Biden we're now over the 5 million
Mark when you include DHS numbers of
people that got into the country that
they didn't count but when you count the
numbers we know and the numbers that
they expect or estimate it's over 5
million people we have enough fentanyl
coming into this country to kill every
American many times over you have cities
like San Francisco they're all over the
country now Geraldo and our children are
dying because of the drugs Crossing that
border when will you join me in saying
if you want to come to America you've
got to do it legally
I join you right now loud and clear the
message I think uh one one I think Sarah
Carter has done a great job Bill mnuchin
our people Greg Hart down there or Griff
Jenkins we have really shown the world
the quantity of people coming across our
Southern border I think that 5 million
figure is grossly exaggerated it counts
people who come we throw them out they
come back we throw them out they come
back they come back and forth it gets
counted as one okay each time it is a
horrible problem it's a terrible problem
we've got to deal with it we need the
wall you're right about that you have
been right from the very beginning but
as you have also said from the very
beginning the wall has to have a great
big door in it why because we need an
orderly practical compassionate
immigration system because we need these
people We're a nation of immigrants
we're down to 3.5 percent unemployment
we have millions of jobs going unfilled
because we just don't have the workers
what we need though is people to follow
the list of the coherent coherent system
let's see what the recession that is is
coming according to all uh all the
experts let's see what how that falls
out here's what I do want to ask you if
you Joe Biden is not only aiding and
abetting the law breaking and allowing
it to happen uh because we have the
lowest numbers in terms of illegal
immigration under Donald Trump he
enforced the law but Joe Biden is
offering preferential treatment people
they don't have to get a vaccine when
they cross the border they don't they
don't even get a Cova test they get a
Biden phone often and they're often you
know they get free transportation to the
to the city of their choice Geraldo now
why don't we have a system that checks
for radical backgrounds and associations
or a system that in the middle of a
pandemic checks for their health or a
system that says you've got to prove
that you can take care of yourself and
won't be a burden on the American people
is that fair
yes it is fair two quick points when you
saw a governor Abbott on the tarmac with
the President Biden that was
unfortunately adversarial but wouldn't
it be nice if they were shoulder to
shoulder if they worked together
Republican and Democrat to fix this
problem it's not going to be fixed with
posturing that's not with Biden's
grandstanding or Governor
it's got to be fixed with people working
together the governor has had to Bear
the brunt of Joe Biden's policies of
aiding and abetting criminal activity by
himself Joe Biden has never been to the
Border until this weekend a whopping
four hours from wheels down to wheels up
and of course they clean out the city so
he doesn't see the reality of what his
policies have caused Geraldo uh I give
the governor of Texas you know great
props for what he did because it was
Brave it was truthful it was honest and
it was a reality check that clearly Joe
needs
well what if if and it's all that and I
give him credit for it as well Sean but
wouldn't it be nice if they sat together
and said okay this is what we have to do
for example Governor Abbott says to
President Biden you know President Biden
you're a nice person you're a kind
person but your kindness is in this case
having a an opposite
political giving people the false
impression that the border is open no I
like the way I like the way Governor
Abbott did it you 20 billion dollars too
late and two years too late and this is
what you've done to my state this is
what you do in our country and it is
having a dramatic negative impact on
cities and states and towns all around
the country and you caused it and you
need to fix it I prefer that letter I'll
give you the last word
I think that you're talking let's just
one thing we haven't mentioned is is
fentanyl fentanyl is the real horrible
difference between years past and now
San Francisco in the film that you
showed of the tenderloin District open
air Drug Mart 500 fentanyl overdose
deaths in the last year alone in that
one city uh London breed the mayor
making that gets up speech uh you know
on crime we're going to clean up the
streets it is a Scourge we have to work
together this is the real test for Kevin
McCarthy this is the real test for
bipartisan approaching Nations problems
the law is the law and right now the law
is we have a process to enter the
country illegally they are entering our
country illegally Geraldo and we as a
country are paying a very dear price for
it so did your forebear Sean
so did my mom's family
wait a minute they came in Legally from
Ellis Island all four grandparents from
Ireland they came in Legally but their
incoming to these people in the South
well you want them to stay don't you you
don't want them in your wall Sean put
Ellis put in Ellis Island office in the
wall that's who you are you're on a wall
with a big door as you've always said
with the needs of the humanitarian needs
to all right I'm going to give you the
last word I am in a very good mood
tonight I just I'm going to let you have
it you deserve it all right Rollo thank
you hey Sean Hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to Fox News YouTube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else